so basically there's this girl on tick
tock right basically she gets paid yeah
to
slide into like girlfriends people's
girlfriends pay her
to slide into their man's dms and chirps
him to see what he'll do what the [ __ ]
is wrong with people what
the [ __ ] is wrong with people
basically the mrs will hollow i said oh
here's my man's instagram
and then she'll slide into the man's dm
women aren't for women fam anyway but
women are not for women because women
aren't for relationships what is that
fam
and then the one that i saw um that was
sent over she's like the girlfriend's
like oh you're gonna have to like think
basically like you're gonna have to
think outside the box because he's smart
so you're gonna actually have to like
you can't just be lackluster with
details actually looking for trouble
like yes
what how does this make sense he's
basically saying he's going to be
faithful
to a point to a point
you make him cheat you need to get past
that point because he's not gonna have
it at first what fam
he had it immediately by then
he had it immediately two two picks on
eye she was like yeah
she slid in he was on it like that yum
the thing is before you continue the
story
i don't understand the end goal slash
benefit of doing something like this
purely because
let's say the man does like you said he
gives in and he talks away chaps or
whatever he kind of cheats emotionally
cheats or whatever how does
that in turn make the actual girlfriend
feel
like [ __ ] obviously she wants to feel
like she clearly that's what she wants
that's what we say a million times is
that like people don't want a happy
relationship
people don't want a happy relationship
days they want drama yeah let me test if
my boyfriend
would take this given given the
opportunity and then you find out he
would even though he hasn't done
anything you find out that he would and
it's like obviously the rest ship's done
and if it's not done it's going to be
the most toxic relationship of all time
but obviously now you've just lost your
partner everything could have been
blessed before then everything's going
to be blessed before then and it's just
like
that whole ignorance is bliss argument
yeah yeah yeah why would you ever want
to know that about the person you love
why why would you ever want to know that
about them
but um anyway yeah he had it immediately
yeah
i think i didn't even watch the whole
time it was long and then but basically
they agreed to meet up
um and then
the girlfriend
came in place of her so he said oh we'll
meet at this did it some cheetahs thing
fam on some cheetos jokes as well
because the girlfriend came in he saw
his girlfriend and he messaged the girl
saying
babes don't come in don't come in he
said he said my ex is here don't come in
he doubled down and ruined it all
he said i'm not not only am i not going
to get caught in this act i still want
my [ __ ] afterwards after i get myself
out of this debug cool he's a bad guy
after i get myself out of this debacle i
still want to secure this now afterwards
wait he wasn't lying his ex truly didn't
know he's she's just ex now yeah yeah
[ __ ] so my ex walked in don't come in
the girl obviously knowing the whole
situation was like nah i'll come in it's
fine and he was like do not come in
she's like i'm not scared like i'll come
in
i'd break out wherever i'm at and break
out of wherever i'm at but this is the
thing that's hilarious guys
you can tell he's young because young
guys will do anything for pom
to the point where like his own mrs
walks in the thing first of all what the
did he not think what are the odds that
my girlfriend's gonna walk in here yeah
so
like his girlfriend walks in in the shop
wherever they're at
and he still thinks i'll need to secure
this nun
i'll be thinking bruv
the jig is up
i've lost my gun and i've lost this
thing
and if it is a coincidence that my girl
just came in here then scrap this thing
yeah yeah yeah it's done yeah yeah it's
done yeah yeah the whole jig is up but
man will fight tooth and nail [ __ ] i'd
run to the toilet oh firm i'm jumping
out the window i'm jumping out the
window that's nuts yeah bro um so i
don't know what happened in the end
between their relationship or whatever
but that's just what she does
and
i was thinking for starters i don't know
why anyone would put themselves through
that i would never do that to my
girlfriend
i would never pay a don
[Music]
i'll never pay a guy
that's the thing is what i was like
there's so many double standards yeah
because like i know for a fact some
girls are probably listening to this or
watching this i'm thinking
yeah
like
makes sense like you want to find out if
your minds are cheap
if
a guy did that or you watched that for
the story from the guy's point of view
and a guy paid a more handsome guy
to move to his girl to see if she would
have it
all the girls would be like this guy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah like that's the
ickiest of the egg how are you gonna pay
next man to flirt with your girl et
cetera et cetera like you're just a
waste of a guy yeah like what's wrong
with you you probably didn't deserve in
the first day if you if you're that
insecure you didn't deserve in the first
place but when is the other way around
it's kind of just kosher comedy it's
literally just comedy today
it's comedy it literally serves him
right yeah and the girlfriend made the
right decision yeah
it's so dumb the dumb the whole thing is
dumb bro
yeah and
you just be happy in the thing that you
got man just be happy the fact that she
said he's smart so you're gonna need to
really really push
ah a man said yes from the jump he said
yes from the offset no from the officer
is hilarious bro but i felt for him
because i was like my god he fell for it
he got gassed uh he saw the k next to
her followers and got gassed
why do that man bro you deserve benefit
brother
is long um but i was thinking
if this
see the girl who does the messaging
if her moral compass was aligned
she
should
say there should be a contracting
and we're like call
i'll take your money and i'll flirt with
homeboy
but
if he doesn't take the bait
and comes back and says [ __ ] off i've
got a girlfriend or whatever
i am then going to tell him
that his girlfriend paid me to flirt to
see what kind of guy he was dying so he
can make the decision yeah
oh
i like that twist that should be a tnc
yeah i like that that should be a time
of the agreement because then the
girlfriend will think twice before
signing this 100 percent she will think
twice 100 would [ __ ] think twice 100
yeah that's a good one she'll think
twice and think [ __ ] i might lose all
good man out of this is it even worth it
nine times out of ten i doubt they'll go
through with it i doubt they'll go
through it